[Applaudissements]
Oui
Je ne sais pas si c'est seulement écrit
oh
je suis domestique
ce n'est pas ça
et moi personne les couteaux ne valent plus
moins d'uniforme animal
[Musique]
deux
Oui
depuis
[Musique]
œil
Oui
[Musique]
durant la semaine
comme ça
Oui
[Musique]
son
ef
Oui
si on sauve le diabétique
[Musique]
et doux
selon la projection
[Musique]
Oui
les yeux
[Musique]
si la disposition
aîné
[Musique]
et si
tas de cheveux
il n'y a pas déjà
je ne sais pas
je
[Musique]
je suis
ne pas
[Musique]
J'arrête
m
[Musique]
et sinon
à présent
[Musique]
et prêt
oh
[Musique]
moi non
Oui oui
et s'ils voyaient
[Musique]
moi-même
non non Non
Oui
[Musique]
non monsieur
et je dis oui
[Musique]
et je me suis dit alors
mais sinon
Oui
et oui aux filles
[Musique]
et jeune
luís bolivar dans le sud
de ce côté
intello
[Applaudissements]